afternoon first to observe Attorney
General bar the pierced have shown an
unsettling willingness to undermine his
own department in order to protect
president trump bars words and actions
suggest he has been disingenuous and
misleading and saying the president is
clear of wrongdoing attorney general
bars letter summarizing the report from
March 24th quoted the special counsel
report quote while this report does not
conclude that the president committed
the crime it also does not exonerate him
he ignored what is in the Muller report
just two sentences before where the
special counsel concluded that quote if
we had confidence after a thorough
investigation of the facts that the
president clearly did not commit
obstruction of justice we would state so
based on the facts and the applicable
legal standards however we are unable to
reach that judgment obviously this
completely changes the emphasis and
meaning of the paragraph and obviously
he didn't include the key sentences
second special counsel ball went on to
say that quote a thorough FBI
investigation would uncover facts about
the campaign and the president
personally that the president could have
understood to be crimes or that would
have risen to personal and political
concerns
close quote for some reason attorney
general Barr excluded this critical
finding as well from his version of
events the Attorney General's decision
to withhold the full report from
Congress is regrettable but no longer
surprising Barr has so far refused to
work with the committee to provide us
with information kind of information
that has been customarily provided in
the past and to which the Judiciary
Committee is entitled these concerns as
many others will be addressed when Barr
testifies before the Committee on mace
even in its incomplete form however the
Muller report incomplete because the
part of it is redacted even in its
incomplete form however the Muller
report outlines disturbing evidence the
president Trump engaged in obstruction
of justice and other misconduct contrary
to the Attorney General's statement this
morning that the White House quote fully
cooperated that quote with the
investigation the report makes clear
that the president refused to be
interviewed by the special counsel and
refused to provide written answers to
follow-up questions page 13 at volume 2
makes clear that his associates
destroyed evidence relevant to the
Russian investigation page 10 volume 1
the report concluded there was
substantial evidence in quotes that
President Trump attempted to prevent an
investigation into his campaign and his
own conduct page 76 page 78 page 19 page
157 volume 2 that is why I have formally
requested that special counsel Muller
testify before the House Judiciary
Committee as soon as possible so we can
get some answers to these critical
questions because we clearly can't
believe with attorney general bartenders
finally it is clear the special counsels
office conducted an incredibly thorough
investigation in order to preserve the
evidence for future investigators the
special counsel made clear that he did
not exonerate the president and the
responsibility now falls to Congress to
hold the president accountable for his
actions Congress must get the full
unredacted report along with the
underlying evidence uncovered by special
counsel Muller Congress requires this
material in order to perform our
constitutionally mandated
responsibilities thank you that's a
statement
that's one possibility there are there
are others we see we obviously have to
get to the bottom of what happened and
take whatever action seems necessary at
that time too early to reach those
conclusions it's one reason we wanted
the model report we still want the
Muller report in its entirety and we
want other evidence to increase we will
proceed with our inquiries I mean the
first thing we will do is make sure we
get the rest of the report and the
underlying evidence we will have
Attorney General Bar testify in front of
the Judiciary Committee in a second I
anticipate that mr. Muller will testify
sometime there's a couple weeks after
that and we will probably hold a series
of hearings on another aspects and we'll
see where we go if you choose to go
toward impeachment how important with
this report be do you think we applied
to roadmap well it's too early to talk
about that you know we will have to go
follow the evidence where it leads and I
don't know exactly where the will lead
if I did know I wouldn't need all this
information but certainly I think from
the structure of the report although I'm
a little tentative because I've only
skimmed it we haven't had it very long I
think it was probably written with the
intent of providing Congress a roadmap
as other reports have in the past and
with a lot of different actions and
others a attorney general bar seems to
be trying to frustrate that intention
okay one more question one more
congressman you said you wanted the hero
promoter to better understand his
findings based on what you've seen from
the report what specifically do you want
to hear from Muller about that you
already don't have them oh there are
dozens of things you want to give me
just give me a few well for example
so art says I don't remember where he
said it was this is verbally with one of
his letter stars he told us that the
special prosecutors determination that
the president that he wasn't going to
indict the President on obstruction
charges had nothing to do with the
Department of Justice doctrine or
opinion that a sitting president is
unindicted as a matter of law there's a
lot of material in the report that seems
to indicate that that doctrine was
considerably important we want to get to
the bottom of that okay thank you very
much thank you thank you thank you
everybody